a new study conducted by researchers in
Arkansas which is where I get most of my
studies from suggests that our pets
might have the same love hormone that
humans have it's called oxytocin and
let's look at some more info on findings
for humans oxytocin or the love hormone
gets released when you're cuddling or
having an intimate experience
researchers tested oxytocin levels in a
dog and a goat after they'd hung out
separately then they let the two animals
hang out together for 15 minutes after
that they checked again the dogs levels
rose by 48 percent which is about how
much of humans would change in a similar
situation and I have an even bigger
number than that the goats levels went
up two hundred and ten percent
no implying that the goat was in love
with the dog is this what gay marriage
was going to lead to No yes bestiality
and not lead to they've been doing this
for thousands of years loving sheep and
goats in the field I mean you know
things get lonely
Stephen Stills put it best love the one
you're with was a sheep shot Rick are
you are you an animal guy - I know
Kelly's a big dog dog lady I'm a big dog
guy I'm a big animal rights person yes I
am yeah so does this surprise you guys
as animal people I love my dog I am
completely confident that my dog loves
me well considering that we are evolved
from these creatures it doesn't surprise
me that we have similar hormones I mean
if you if if you believe in evolution it
makes perfect sense and yeah and I think
they're finding out more and more now
that animals have a real inner emotional
life I mean isn't there a chimpanzee
suing his owners right now for Missy
treatments like a little cover of Time
magazine
yeah something crazy like recovery
though it's yeah next week you can cover
next week but they're funny they're
having this they have an inner emotional
life which you know really then goes to
the argument for we should not be animal
testing
we shouldn't ultimately be eating these
creatures and yet we evolved with them
and I can't do my weight at pet stores
you see them as a tiny old thing and
their feet are on those little bars on
the bottom there and it's like that it's
that same idea you're watching a pace
you're watching it go crazy like a
prison well yeah it is absolutely it but
my thing about this which is you know
science is finding out all sorts of
amazing things about the brain and the
body and it's it's basically you know
it's it's discovering you know why we
oxytocin why we connect why we you know
the god thing you know the parts of our
brain that has that in it and it all
gets down reduced to cells and chemicals
and everything which to me is depressing
I mean right you know Shakespearean you
know sonnets and Baudelaire poetry I I
want to believe in that and I think
there's a way you know from you know
being Old Testament and then through
rational science important important but
I think you have to also give that there
is something else between us you know
yes it's oxytocin and and what else
though you know I think that's exactly
what I Circle ten times here so that
part that part that's between science
and the part of us that's very human
that wants to believe that love is in
some oxytocin or some Mito chlorines if
we were in Star Wars or something you
know like a ritual aspect yeah I love
comedy but comedy isn't emitting some
big kingdom hormones you know it's I
love it on a spiritual bond because the
spiritual bond is I have a hunger for
certain things in my heart and this
energy comes in and starts to fill the
cup up I respond to that and I want I
will feed back and to start the loop
going because I on an animal level I
want to be near it I want to feed from
it some more but on a healthy level
that's what all love is based on
recognizing something that made you feel
good that's a need field yeah and I
think exactly and I think it's it is
about creating meaning in your life yes
it can be this chemical thing but our
minds these amazing big frontal lobes
are the things that create meaning and
and that gives life its power and and
why we're here and why we stick around
you know so
and science can't [ __ ] with that you
know I mean it is what we do with it
we've taken chemicals and made meaning
out of it I mean look how amazing we are
you know sure the goat no dog I love
each other but maybe they don't have any
meaning around it we we would have a
whole story around yeah speaking of
chemicals - so going from from the
chemicals - to our brains how long until
we put this in pill form because now it
seems to me if we can isolate this thing
if we're good at one thing around here
it's putting everything in pill form and
we'll have a little oxytocin pill and
you'll pop that with a Viagra and
there's your there's your rom-com they
never intended to fall in love timing
you know I think actually if they could
put it in a pill form I it could save us
all because it is the ultimate love
child flower power moment I mean it is
that if everyone took ecstasy at the
same time on planet Earth we've come
across master something like really
amazing happen just with that oxytocin
powder yeah